[Music]  well now to economic news where bars and  restaurants are struggling to stay  afloat and local governments are not  allowing them to sell drinks to go  i've got more rice in sweden  more makers than eden  more 12 12-year-old whites than prince  andrew  i've got more melon squeezings  than redskins team meetings  but how i'll make rent i haven't a clue  [Music]  wasting away here in no margaritaville  [Music]  wishing i could sell cocktails to go  but the government claims we'd be a  gross kind of place  just like these where you can drink  outdoors  [Applause]  i've got swanky bacardi  more tank than a swat team  more fingers of johnny than amber  [Music]  if there's no ceiling above you  while you're sipping on cuff ya i guess  us going  under is what they prefer  [Music]  wasting away here in no margaritas bill  fully stocked with cocktails shakers and  salt  some people will we put too many  in jail well these laws  might be a good place to start